here in this video we will showcase and
explain the eight monsters that appeared
in the second season of the witcher
spoilers ahead we will not be including
the cursed humans that appear as
monsters and nor will we include the
wildlife of that show so without further
ado subscribe to be a part of the
minecube family and now let's get down
to business
number one the brookser seen in the
first episode the broxah is the first
monster that geralt battles and was the
cause of an entire village disappearing
while the brookside can shapeshift into
a lovely human woman her actual form is
that of a large vampiric bat with wings
capable of great feats of agility flying
at tremendous speeds it has super
strength and endurance capable of
withstanding even being impaled right
through the chest
the only way to kill one is to cut off
the head those who happens to catch a
glimpse of her mouth will be shocked as
she dislocates her jaw revealing double
rows of needle-like fangs this monster
is the size of a human with a wingspan
of around 15 to 20 feet across
number two the lesson highly intelligent
polymorphic iron resistant hunters the
legends is a monster who haunts the
continent's forest hanging around
walking and waiting to slaughter humans
who dare to enter their domain
though they do have a wild guard slash
bear form they most often are seen in
human suits or as human tree hybrids the
legend looks a lot like a tree yet it
has certain more humanoid traits that
set it apart branches clustered together
to form limbs legs and antlers allowing
them to fit seamlessly into their
natural habitat which they jealously
guard and rarely leave the main lesson
seen in season 2 was around 12 to 15
feet tall with roon-like limbs and can
stretch hundreds of feet from its body
number three the myriapod in the books
the meripot is essentially described as
enormous centipede and is featured in
the short story of the sword of destiny
the mere report from season 2 on the
other hand could be a whole other
creature it features the body of a
centipede a bulbous four-eyed demon head
with bulls horns and spiky arms resemble
those of gigantic praying mantises the
beasts also have a slew of human arms
emerging from its torso some of which
flail around as the assault while others
clutch the creature's own chest in an
attempt to defend it this beast is one
of geralt's most terrifying foes it
killed the legend the one that was seen
in season 2 as easily as snapping a
dried stick it looks to be around 5 to 6
meters or 16 to 20 feet long
number 4 the zoogle another terrifying
monster that was seen in the second
season the zoo girl is a classic monster
of the witcher franchise zeugel's
inhabit series predominantly feeding on
sewage and grows at an alarming rate the
beast is always hungry so it reaches out
with its tentacles for living creatures
and tries to shove them into its huge
mall filled with multiple rows of teeth
this specific zergle from season 2
prefers the city oxenfurt's foul sewers
with large mouth packed with many rows
of fangs it often makes quick work of
anyone dumb enough to approach its
habitat although in the series we hardly
see the entire body but just the
tentacles as it snatches and elf and
yennefer to feed on them its size is up
to anyone's guess but it would
definitely be more than 30 to 40 feet
long as per our estimates
number five the chernobyl
little is known about this mystery
monster which appeared from the
destroyed monolith in sintra it looks
like a demonic dragon with its black
exoskeleton bright yellow eyes and
massive wings as well as razor-sharp
fangs and talents which proved to be
highly deadly
this monster has never been seen or
described in the witcher books or games
and it was a delight to see it in the
series this monster seems to have a
combination of flesh and stone in its
body it has two long full limbs and even
longer legs that are all armored in
black monolithic stones it is around 20
feet tall and has a wingspan of around
50 to 60 feet across
number 6 the basilisk in the final
episode of the season we get to see the
monsters that have been mentioned quite
a lot in the show three basilisks two
black ones and an albino came out from a
portal created by volath mere the
basilisks are snake-like monsters that
has been known to have multiple feathers
on occasion but here they seem to look
like black and white this monster has
the head and a neck of a snake the body
of a dinosaur but filled with
raptor-like feathers and feet of a bird
of prey its powerful fangs make it a
formidable close quarters opponent and
has venom that is highly lethal even
burning through geralt's armor and also
swiped from its tail can be quite lethal
the two black basilisks were around
eight to nine feet tall and thirty feet
long but the albino was larger number 7
volath mir also known as the deathless
mother this is a demon who feeds on
suffering she usually takes on the
appearance of an elderly human woman
however this depends on the person with
whom she is engaging with during the
conjunction of the spheres demons like
her came on the continent and the first
witchers were hired to deal with volath
mere whom they later endured in her hut
beneath an elf ruin in the north in the
series she sorts out siri in order to
return back to her own dimension as a
demon she can shapeshift to look like
any human or elf but her most impressive
form was that of her own hut with two
basilisk legs putting her at a height of
around 30 feet
and lastly number 8 the raids of morhawk
closely resembling the four horsemen of
the apocalypse the raids of mohawk are
more numerous but still signify the same
meaning
they are also called the wild hun or the
race of mohawk as they are called in
skillish and was widely believed to be a
group of specters galloping in the sky
they were described by common folk as a
group of raids on undead horses seen
galloping across the sky and serving as
an omen of war but their origins are
deeper than that essentially they are
powerful elves that travel to other
realms in their spectral form and wage
war in order to capture and enslave the
population of such unfortunate worlds
and yeah so i hope you have enjoyed
watching this video anyway with that we
come to the end of it so do hit that
like button for support and subscribe as
well to be a part of the mind cue family
but most of all smash that bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care farm